tu connais le nom de tout le monde ici
dernier évidemment bien évidemment c'est
quoi c est ça le csa les gens ne vous
appelle papa oui c'est vrai c'est
exactement ce qu'on m'a dit tu vas
donner un mot pour chacun
lui c'est qui lui euh prison ferme ces
missions sont musulmans
attendez on peut reprendre les champions
demi molle points il est très forte et à
cause du vent sortez sortez allez vous
oui ou non à lui mais ça à thierry
moreau moins cher la dame à côté mais là
depuis 94
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ce n'est pas une école c'est vrai que je
rappelle qu'elle est et bella dans le
guide s'était bel la wii maintenant oui
c'est bella si bella et balsa bella non
mais vous êtes toujours charmante
vraiment vraiment alors oui la personne
n'a le nouveau chômeur c'est ce qui
s'appelle morini bosc à la grande copine
de clovis à côté côté ceux qui le bilal
assadi grec à côté ceglia jeudi à côté à
ces noms c'est ma grande copine
eh bien c'est géraldine non mais
géraldine maillet non non je peux pas me
touche pas non non non l'idée bouquin
sans images géraldine maillet bien sûr
et enfin jean edouard et loana
[Rires]
la bague à sa vie bravo
[Applaudissements]